hey guys Ryan right here I wanted to
make a public confession something that
means a lot to me and I wrote a poem I
wrote a poem for this man a man who has
greatly changed my life in every
possible way and
ryan gosling changed my life I'm sorry I
don't have a chorus to go with this I
don't have a I don't have a music video
I don't have the recording studio I
don't have all this [ __ ] that other
people have when they have a song they
could create for someone put out there
but no all I have is this camera and my
computer with my lyrics on it so it's
about time people know the truth love
the other night thinking about you in my
sight righting wrongs right and rights
plane a hero while I fell like a zero
seeing a picture on the front of Cosmo
and suddenly I'm questioning an ayah
homo thinking about all the nights I
look up to the sky praying to God this
is Ryan right and if you're really God
from the above could I call this crazy
stupid love there's so much confusion
falling in love with an illusion let I
got a confession to make I think we're
meant to be fate those performances man
I can really relate I thought I was
straight but you're way too [ __ ]
great but there's a baby along the way
am I too [ __ ] late I wanna kiss you
all night long while I'm serenading you
with the song as I sing to Ryan Gosling
I'm thinking about the acting that he
does bring my hardest eight you just
want to do some banging with Ryan
Gosling am I out of line with these near
arms agreeing with the ladies of the
skies so [ __ ] fun I have so much
ambition to grab the attention of this
beautiful Canadian I remember that you
was on a November I remember that you
was a damn good kisser in the notebook
my heart
don't want to taste those lips and suck
on your nips if I gotta just have a
speck of those rock-hard pecs
hell even read you a blank check if you
let me suck on your beautiful deck take
this next sentence literal whenever you
get emotional I begin to ball man I do
like a tall man I too dated a blow-up
doll man had it custom-made to look just
like you came to come I did install man
you're an even six feet as I stained my
bedsheets
I get pissed off that you never [ __ ]
tweak young Hercules got new and
improved now he's having baby but maybe
he'll change his mind for this brand-new
dude let me take you out for drinks at
the canadian pub talk about how you bugs
Britney in the Mickey Mouse Club was
timber lagaye was that you Lera cray
was it hard having a workday with a
bunch of crazies caught a glimpse of you
and remember the titans began pushing my
buttons man [ __ ] that movie had me so
[ __ ] antsy because he was in and
barely just read an article the other
day that did say you didn't get along
with ms McAdams I first heard she had a
burst and then cursed but it couldn't
have been the worst because how can you
resist the gusting power when 70% of the
world is water a but [ __ ] is still
thirst
Ryan my soul out there I really wanna
share just not much I care that as I
stare into your prolong stares pictures
naked
underwear hey girl
want me to cook you some pancakes do you
ever get baked do you want to go skinny
dipping in a lake without the COS send
my heart into a state of aftershock I
was feeling blue without you was my
Valentine and thinking about you and how
you just redefine all acting when you
did the place beyond the pines when I
asked you what you do I want you to say
I Drive drive my ass all night [ __ ]
long cuz you make me feel alive without
you I wouldn't have survived all the
[ __ ] I've been through my hair is
too curly but I want your [ __ ] hairdo
when I look into your blue eyes as you
do cry ask myself why why am i so
obsessive this guy I'll make you my
whole by being the other half-nelson
ever been with a half Italian half asian
hey girl I'd show you a new definition
of heaven there's just a movie title
named all good things
it'll be about depression if it stars
Ryan Gosling what was it like working
with George Clooney ask if he's down for
three something's clearly I'm soaked
mother [ __ ] horny step to the side
evil cuz he's gonna be the one that's
gonna wanna be with me forever Gangster
Squad
how about against a bang get you flexing
your quads [ __ ] we go together
like in and [ __ ] game if God is
real we'll only God forgives but God I
can no longer live if you don't let me
be with Ryan cuz every night I'm crying
every night I'm dying how my heart is
taking my piss unclenching and my dick
I'm beating I know I sound like I'm
repeating so here comes the ending
number instrumental than a blackboard